hi my name's samuel leeds i'm a property
investor and developer and i've been
investing in property now for 12 years
i've done over 300 property deals
and i'm going to share in this video my
knowledge with you into how
you can predict what the end value is
going to be on a property
because if you're doing a property let's
say it's a fix and flip or
let's say you're buying it to add value
and then to refinance it we call those
brr by refurbished refinance rent or
burr deals how do you this is the golden
question
to property developers and property
investors how do you predict
what the end value is going to be
because if you buy a property
let's say for a hundred thousand pounds
and you fix it up
and you think once this is done it's
going to be worth 200 000 pounds
but then it gets down valued by a valuer
or if you're trying to sell it
no one wants to buy it for two hundred
thousand pounds that's a problem
because it was only worth two hundred
thousand pounds in your mind
in your optimistic rose-colored glasses
mind and the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs is they do tend to be
optimistic so
how do you be realistic rather than
optimistic when it comes to the end
value
so there's three things that you can do
the first thing you can do
is when you're first looking at the
property let's say it's an auction
property
and you and you're looking at it and
you're trying to think okay what's the
end value i would approach
three independent estate agents
and say to them i've got this property
it's on church road
this is the property what do you think
the value would be if it was done up
nice
what would be the end value and they'll
give you an idea now the problem with a
lot of
uh property developers is they'll speak
to the estate agent that's actually
selling the house
now the estate that's selling the house
they'll tell you what you want to hear
because they just want to sell you the
house so first thing speak to three
independent estate agents and get their
advice because they know they're gonna
have more a better idea than just about
anybody because that's what they do day
in day out
they sell houses i used to be an estate
agent i used to work in great bar
birmingham
and i knew the great bar area really
really well so that's the first thing
speak to three independent estate agents
not
the one estate agent that's selling you
the house by the way if you're enjoying
this video do me a massive favor
smash the like button okay smash the
like button second way
is to do your own due diligence and you
can do this by let's say you've got a
property
again on church road you go on
rightmove.co.uk
and there's other websites you can do
this you can go on mouseprice.com
there are other websites but what you
want to do is you want to look up
these sold houses in that street
over the last two years and try and
stick within quarter of a mile
now if there are no sold properties in
that street or within quarter of a mile
you can look up to half a mile but the
further you go
away from the house the less like for
like it is
and you want to see what property has
sold
that's similar to this property within
quarter of a mile
over the last two years and again if
there's nothing that sold over the last
two years maybe look over the last three
or four years
but again if you start looking at what
happened five six seven eight years ago
that was a completely different market
then and house prices do
change they do fluctuate now by finding
by finding like for like comparables
yourself again really important don't be
optimistic
don't say well this property sold for
100 grand in the street therefore mine
well
because maybe that property was had an
extension
so you need to be finding a like for
like so that's the second thing
do your own due diligence find like for
like properties that sold
within the last two years within quarter
of a mile
and then the third thing you can do is
if you really need to know exactly what
the end value is going to be
is you can just pay a few hundred pounds
to have a valuer go out to the property
and tell you what the end value is going
to be now
they'll they're going to tell you based
on the quality of the refurb so they
might say if the refurb's to a really
high standard
the n value is going to be 200 000
pounds and it's important to get an idea
of what kind of
quality the refurb needs to be done but
that's the third way
if it's a big project and it's you know
it's potentially
a unique property and you're putting a
lot of money and a lot of risk into the
deal
always get a valuer to go out and tell
you what they predict the end value to
be
another little tip is if you want to be
conservative knock off 10
of what you think the end value will be
of what you think the value's going to
knock off 10
because you do not want to be overly
optimistic and then get caught out
when the when the property gets down
valued so those are the three ways i
hope you found this video useful
get three independent estate agents do
your own due diligence and look at local
properties that have sold in the area
and if all else fails
get a valuer to go to the property there
are other things you can do as well
and we do go into great detail at the
property investors crash course
about how to value a house how to
negotiate the house and we go through
the whole process so
if you've not been to the property
investors crash course i'd like to give
you a free gift
you can come on the house is two days
with me i'll leave a link in the
description
and again subscribe to the channel and i
hope this has been helpful i'll see you
next time thanks